de quoi tu parles quoi d'autre bien
sûr c'est un agresseur d'enfants genre de
trou du cul qui fait vraiment mal te faire tomber
tout ce que je dis c'est que ce que tu dis c'est des
conneries châtaigne ce n'est pas le boogeyman
et la boucle d'oreille du diable dans ce vieux
conte de femmes homme grincheux  J'ai demandé aux gars d'avoir un
nom, ils se chieront comme n'importe qui d'
autre quand on le traînera sur la chaise tu
sais beaucoup de choses ne
nous dis pas donne moi un autre entendu que Beth
hé écoute tu nous racontes dans l'histoire de la vie
ouais eh bien tout ce que je dis, c'est que nous voulons
ici attraper un fantôme à droite, je fais juste
des acclamations de conversation À votre santé ouais
mesdames messieurs
Dark Knight est de retour vivant ce matin
est déjà sur sa quatrième coupe de golf un
court noir sans sucre eh bien il est  Je dois rester
assis toute la nuit dans sa voiture hé les gars qui s'amusent
à faire ses conneries et tout
ça pour ce que nous sommes morts je veux dire Sherlock
Holmes ouais comme sur des roulettes le dernier enfant a
disparu il y a deux mois ne sera pas long
avant que le prochain ne reparte Dieu est de retour sur
le  différence de piste  e va faire que je suis
Julia villes déjà finies